empecemos a programar para iniciar
dibujemos un círculo
podemos hacerlo mediante la emisión de
un comando a nuestro programa de
computadora y hemos hecho que puedas ver
fácilmente los comandos que están
disponibles en esta caja de herramientas
ves el comando que tiene la figura de un
óvalo y la palabra elipse si nunca
habías oído el término elipse significa
básicamente lo mismo que óvalo y es el
comando que usaremos voy a tomarlo y
arrastrarlo a la zona de código y
sorpresa hay una elipse en mi pantalla
en realidad esta elipse parece un
círculo perfecto porque su anchura y su
altura son las mismas que pasa si
arrastramos otro comando de elipse ops
no pasa nada en realidad si pasó algo
dibujamos otra elipse exactamente en el
mismo lugar sobre la elipse que ya
teníamos es por eso que estos cuatro
números son importantes porque ellos
determinan dónde y cómo se dibuja la
elipse tenemos los mismos cuatro números
en estas elipses por lo que está una
sobre otra y eso es bastante absurdo
fíjate en estos cuatro números y trata
de adivinar que
cada uno de ellos en la elipse en
realidad una manera de averiguarlo es
cambiar los números y ver qué pasa vamos
a hacerlo con este primer número usar el
cambiador de números que está aquí y voy
a hacer clic para ir al otro lado de la
pantalla así que este número parece
controlar la distancia de la elipse al
lado izquierdo de la pantalla
ahora el segundo número conforme cambio
este número se mueve hacia abajo así que
parece controlar qué tan abajo está de
la parte superior de la pantalla ok el
tercer número vamos a ver qué pasa se
hace más ancha así que este controla la
anchura finalmente el cuarto número que
crees que haga este número bueno que
falta la altura este hace la elipse más
alta y ahora tal vez puedes entender por
qué el comando de elipse originalmente
dibuja un círculo porque la anchura y la
altura son de 100 y eso hace un círculo
perfecto del mismo tamaño por todos
lados
entre más cambiamos estos números entre
ellos menos parecerá un círculo perfecto
este de 185 y 306 no es muy circular en
realidad ahora sabemos lo que hace cada
uno de estos cuatro números los primeros
dos controlan la posición y los
siguientes dos controlan el tamaño a
estos números los llamamos parámetros
del comando de leeds en realidad en
programación generalmente a un comando
lo llamamos función aquí en nuestro
programa estamos llamando a la función
de dip
dando cuatro parámetros para cambiar la
forma en la que se dibuja la elipse
ahora que sabemos cómo funcionan estos
números vamos a tratar de dibujar algo
una cara ya tenemos aquí la forma de la
cara sólo nos falta agregar los ojos y
una boca vamos a pasar esta de aquí a la
boca queremos esta elipse aquí abajo
en primer lugar voy a cambiar el primer
número que debe estar más alejado de la
izquierda ok se ve bien ahora voy a
cambiar este número debe estar más abajo
se ve grandioso después voy a hacerla
más grande una boca loca muy bien ahora
voy a arrastrar otra elipse para el ojo
éste debe ir aquí así que la voy a mover
un poco y la voy a bajar un poco no debe
estar en la orilla de la cabeza
es un poco grande así está mejor hermosa
vamos a poner otro ojo este no es un
cíclope
aunque los cíclope son hermosos
déjenme mover este hasta acá
hermoso después no voy a mover hacia
abajo y lo voy a hacer un poco más
delgado o me encanta se ve muy bien
en este programa dibujamos una cara
llamando a la función elipse cuatro
veces y especificando cuatro parámetros
cada vez que llamamos la función no
todas las funciones en programación
tienen parámetros pero muchas de ellas
sí porque cuando quieres decirle a un
programa que haga una cosa en particular
también tienes que darle al programa
algunos detalles sobre cómo hacer esa
cosa piensa en lo aburrido que sería si
sólo pudiéramos dibujar una lista en el
mismo lugar cuando describimos los
parámetros que necesita una función
generalmente le pasamos un alias para
que no tengamos que decirle el primero y
el segundo y el tercero y el cuarto aquí
en realidad mostramos alias sobre los
números para ayudarte vamos a ver el
primero lo llamamos x porque pensamos en
la dirección de x que pasa a través de
la pantalla de izquierda a derecha desde
cero hasta 400 al segundo parámetro lo
llamamos bien porque pensamos en la
dirección de jacques que va de arriba a
abajo de 0 a 400 es un poco diferente de
una cuadrícula si eso es a lo que estás
acostumbrado porque generalmente en
matemáticas el punto cero cero está en
centro y la va hacia arriba desde aquí
en este caso nuestro punto 0 0 está aquí
y nuestra lleva desde 0 incrementándose
hacia abajo hasta 400 es un poco
diferente es algo a lo que te
acostumbrarás al tercer parámetro lo
llamamos wifi porque es la anchura y el
cuarto height porque es la altura y
usamos doble vih porque no podemos poner
palabras más largas aquí
ok entendiste lo harás pronto porque vas
a practicar algo de código de arrastrar
y soltar por ti mismo y si tienes
curiosidad por todas las funciones de tu
caja de herramientas mantente al tanto
hablaremos de ellas justo después del
desafío